[Music]
today for our daily cancellation we will
respond to a video from um a youtuber
named professor dave of the channel
professor dave explains where presumably
professor dave explains things the
channel has an impressive two million
subscribers and this video was sent to
me by several people promising that it
contains a formidable argument against
my position on gender ideology one
person in fact says that professor dave
debunks my movie what is a woman and i'm
quite interested to see that so let's uh
go through this together
everybody seems to be furious about
trans people half of us are furious that
they exist and the other half are
furious about what the other half is
saying i would like to jump in and see
if i can clear up some of the ways that
people are talking past each other
now it's no secret that i'm a bit on the
liberal side but rest assured the left
is not going to get away scot-free on
this one they're missing the mark on a
few key points but as tends to be the
case it's bigots on the right who are
the main problem so let's start there
we're off to a rough start putting aside
dave's smug know-it-all tone and
demeanor something that seems to be a
matter of instinct for people like him
so i'm not gonna hold her against him
the real problem is that in the very
first sentence he's already wildly and
intentionally mischaracterizing his
opponents in 30 seconds he gives us a
straw man and an ad ad hominem he's
doing that in the first 30 seconds he's
beginning this way
which signals that he doesn't have much
to offer beyond this point because if he
actually planned on making a compelling
argument he wouldn't come out of the
gate breezily dismissing millions of
people as bigots sorry not millions
billions
because anybody who has a problem with
basic concepts of of gender ideology is
a bigot he says which means that almost
everybody in the world and who has ever
existed in the world is a bigot
professor dave begins the proceedings
with that declaration he also lies about
the nature of the opposing argument and
he does it in the laziest and frankly
dumbest way imaginable he says that the
people on the other side are furious
that trans people exist
now in reality as he's well aware we're
not furious that trans people exist but
rather we deny the underlying premise of
gender ideology if we're furious about
anything it's that this ideology is
being imposed on society and especially
on children and it's causing great harm
in the process by saying that we're
furious that trans people exist he gets
to dismiss all of us as a bunch of angry
spittle flecked rage clowns
when he is also quite well aware that
when it comes to this subject nearly all
of the angry spittle flecked rage clowns
are on the other side of the discussion
take for example the people threatening
to kill me and accusing me of genocide
for making a documentary a documentary
where i am only visibly angry one time
briefly when addressing a school board
that covered up the rape of a student so
perhaps you'll excuse my emotions
in that case
but the other point of this
mischaracterization is to pretend that
we're angry at trans people personally
rather than critical of the claims made
by trans activists
overall it's a mess and we're only 30
seconds in let's continue
the primary issue is people who deny
transgenderism these are the people who
spew the tired fox news talking points
liberals say there are 89 genders and
anyone can identify as a hamster that
sort of thing it's a deliberate
caricature of reality peddled by all the
angry conservative dudes popping up in
my feed lately who claim that nobody can
define a woman let's all take a moment
to acknowledge the problems that go
along with the ambiguity of language sex
and gender are different words that
refer to different things if you did not
know that now you do
so we we have another common rhetorical
tactic from the left and honestly i'm
quite disappointed to hear common
rhetorical tactics when i was promised
in utter destruction of my worldview and
i was looking forward to it professor
dave says it's a tired fox news talking
point that there are a lot of genders
but that's not fox's talking point
that's his talking point this is indeed
the official position of the gender
ideologue they may they may disagree on
how many genders but they all agree that
there are a lot more than two some say
there are infinite numbers facebook says
there are 58. if this sounds insane
that's not fox's fault
as for sex and gender being two
different things um i totally agree sex
refers to biology while gender is a
linguistic term that refers to words but
was co-opted by a pedophile sexologist
named john money and applied to people
in a vague and ambiguous way
dave never mentions that point he
doesn't seem to know where his own ideas
came from or or else he doesn't want you
to know
ignorant or deceptive you decide from
here professor dave provides a basically
correct definition of sex with a long
digression into intersexuality and then
gets around to talking about gender
let's listen to that
gender is a different phenomenon it is
still biological but it is a
neurochemical construct
this means that ultimately it is still
genetic in basis but it absolutely is
not determined merely by the sex
chromosomes it is tremendously more
complicated and researchers are still
working to understand the biological
basis of gender identity human
psychology is complex people need to
deal with that thoughts and feelings are
ultimately chemical phenomena we all
have a neurochemical profile that guides
how we think and feel and part of that
is gender identity the reason that we
are just now becoming equipped to
differentiate between the two phenomena
is that in the vast majority of humans
somewhere between 99 and 99.9
of all people gender identity aligns
with biological sex
so gender identity has a neurochemical
basis because it's a feeling and
feelings can be traced back
to brain activity
uh okay sure
i'll buy that
the question is whether those feelings
reflect reality that's the question
an anorexic person feels that she's
overweight the feeling is a biological
phenomenon in the sense that it's
happening in her brain in the same sense
that a man feels like a woman but we
understand in her case that the feelings
are disordered incorrect wrong
delusional and so we work to treat her
brain her feelings to more accurately
align them with reality we don't say
that the anorexic is trans obese and we
don't call actually obese people cis
obese
we understand that there's physical
reality and then feelings and sometimes
feelings are out of step with reality
and when that's the case we usually
understand that the feelings are the
issue they are the problem to be solved
and so we try to solve them will
professor dave address that objection in
this video spoiler no he won't in fact
he won't honestly engage with literally
any objection raised by the opponents of
his ideology at all won't even try
common theme
with these people but let's keep
listening anyway
the unfortunate linguistic coincidence
is that we use terms like man and woman
or male and female in describing both of
these phenomena that is where the
confusion arises when people insist that
one term must encapsulate both phenomena
at once
so when someone asks what is a woman
expecting to get a very simple answer
that children can understand they are
sorely mistaken the answer requires a
discussion of genetics and
neurochemistry
well i'm sorry you find it offensive
dave but yes i do deny the concept of
gender as it was conceived by john money
you accept that concept as gospel you're
offended that anybody disagrees with it
that's your problem meanwhile you say
that the definition of the word woman is
complicated but please note that
it's complicated is not a definition so
you still haven't defined it i never
insisted on a simple definition i simply
insist on a definition any kind of
definition some sort of meaning you can
give me a complicated one that's fine go
ahead try me give me a complicated
definition i i'm perfectly fine with
that
but you must have some definition
whereas you provide none at all
see this is a major problem for you dave
and let me try to explain why it's a
problem because and listen closely
you are using the word do you see why
that's an issue
you say the word woman is complicated
and apparently ambiguous and hard to
understand
yet you use it
you refer to women you talk about women
i bet you'd even say that you believe in
women's rights would you say that i bet
you would
this must mean that you have some solid
comprehensible idea of what a woman is
yet you never explain that idea that's a
very big problem for you dave you're
using a word that you cannot or will not
define which means either that you're
hopelessly confused and we should
dismiss you and your arguments for that
reason or you're evasive and
disingenuous and we should dismiss you
and your arguments for that reason
either way you and your arguments are in
really bad shape right now let's
continue
the acceptance for suppressed sexual
orientations came first because around
10 percent of people are gay whereas a
much smaller percentage of people are
trans but this is the natural
progression of societal evolution nearly
every binary has been shown to actually
be a spectrum and it doesn't matter how
uncomfortable it makes conservative
people
wait what
nearly every binary is a spectrum like
what
no i'm not uncomfortable with that i
just think it's nonsense it's just it's
just
that's i mean in a certain way i'm
uncomfortable around
people saying stupid things but that's
all we mean by that what are the
binaries that turned out to be spectrums
don't say gender because that's begging
the question i don't agree
with john money's concept of gender at
all it's not that i think gender is a
binary it's that i think it's a totally
useless and incoherent concept that
should be put back into the world of
linguistics and grammar where it belongs
as for sex if that's not a binary then
what is it there are males and females
there are those who are of the nature to
become pregnant and those who are of the
nature to impregnate there's no third
sex it's a binary so where is the
spectrum that everyone thought was a
binary can you give one example
as for the claim that 10 of people are
gay where did you come up with that
where'd you get that from well i'll tell
you where you got it from uh you got
that from alfred kinsey who made that
claim in his book sexual behavior of the
human male which is the same book that
contains a chart documenting the orgasms
of infants he arrives at his arguments
and his figures about human sexuality by
interviewing sex offenders and prison
inmates and lying and pretending that he
surveyed a cross-section of the
population but he didn't so that's where
you're getting your information
professor i just thought you might like
to know that let's watch a little bit
more
now as promised with the indictment of
conservatives complete i turn to
liberals and the missteps they are
enacting that are preventing resolution
number one please stop saying things
like gender is a social construct
no it is not it is a biological
construct society can't turn you trans
any more than it can turn you gay gender
is determined biologically
his indictment of conservatives was
complete without ever approaching the
vicinity of any one of our actual
arguments and then he turns to
criticized liberals to prove how fair
and objective he is
by slamming them for not being liberal
enough
he also says that society can't turn you
trans totally ignoring the fact that in
our society currently and only in our
society only in the west there has been
a manifold increase in trans
identification if that's not society
turning people trans what is it dave
now
i don't know what you'd say to that
because as always and like literally
every other gender ideologue i've ever
spoken to and i guarantee i've spoken
personally to many more people on your
side than you've spoken to on my side
but like all of them you don't attempt
to grapple with any of the logical
inconsistencies of your position but i
ask again anyway if society can't turn
you trans why are we experiencing an
unprecedented skyrocketing rise
in trans identifications if you say that
there have always been this many trans
people but they were all in the closet
you'll then have to explain why there
was never ever at any point ever a mass
epidemic of people committing suicide
because they were not affirmed in their
gender identity after all staple
doctrine on the left is that lack of
affirmation is dangerous because it
causes suicide well then why was that
never happening back when there were
millions and millions of supposed
unaffirmed trans people
indeed why is the suicide epidemic
happening now when trans people are so
affirmed
here's my answer
gender ideology is a modern western
social construct that didn't exist until
it was invented by psychoanalytical
quacks and then parroted mindlessly by
people like you further while pretending
that it affirms and nurtures people it
actually leads them into
self-destruction and despair
the evidence bears that out the evidence
is entirely on my side in fact and not
at all on your side because on this
topic you are wrong about nearly
everything and your underlying claims
are so nonsensical and incoherent that
you can't begin to explain them or
defend them and that's why you don't
even try
which is a long way of saying professor
dave that you are today canceled
if you enjoyed this video be sure to
give it a thumbs up and share it with
all your friends
you